[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je suis le dauphin de la Place dauphine
et la place blanche
Maua les camions sont pleins de lait
palur sont plein de B IL est
[Musique]
5h
Je sais
voir les travestis vont se raser les
les striptis sont
rill les traversin sont écrasés les
amoureuses sont fatiguées IL est
5h
paire
s'éveille
Paris
le café dans les tasses les cafés
nettoient leur
[Musique]
glace et Sur le Boulevard Montparnasse
La gare n'est plus qu'une carcasse IL
c'est t
[Musique]
5h
Paris les panards sont dans les
la villette sur tranche le
[Musique]
l Paris by night regag l'écart les
boulangers font des batards IL est
5h
J'ai arrêté je sais
voile
Paris
[Musique]
s'éveille la tour est fait la froid Au
pied l'arc de triomphe est ranimer
[Musique]
est bien habillé entre la nuit et la
journée IL est
5h
[Musique]
Paris
Les journaux sont imprimés
les ouvriers sont
[Musique]
déprimé les gens sont lventure ou je vais
je
[Applaudissements]
coucher IL est
5h Paris
J'ai IL est
5h Je n'ai pas
[Musique]
dormir